ich rufe nun auf die Tagesordnungspunkte
7a bis 7c erste Beratung des von der
Bundesregierung eingebrachten
Gesetzentwurfs zur Änderung des zweiten
Buches Sozialgesetzbuch und anderer
Gesetze Einführung eines Bürgergeldes so
wie Beratung des Antrages der Fraktion
der AFD mit dem Titel aktivierende
Grundsicherung statt bedingungslosem
Grundeinkommen Einführung von
Bürgerarbeit und Beratung des Antrags
der Fraktion Die Linke mit dem Titel
sozialen Arbeitsmarkt ausbauen 150.000
Langzeitarbeitslose in Erwerbsarbeit
bringen
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
68 Minuten vereinbart
ich eröffne nun die Aussprache und als
erstes hat das Wort für die
Bundesregierung der Bundesminister für
Arbeit und Soziales Hubertus Heil
eine sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Bundesregierung hat sich mit der
Einführung des Bundes des Bürgergeldes
zwei zentrale Ziele gesetzt erstens wir
wollen Menschen
verlässlich absichern die in
existenzielle Not geraten sind und wie
schnell das geht haben wir in den
letzten zwei Jahren der
wirtschaftspandemie der corona-pandemie
erlebt wir haben erlebt dass
Solo-Selbständige die nie gedacht haben
dass sie mal auf ergänzende
Grundsicherung angewiesen sind darauf
zurückgreifen mussten und wir haben auch
erlebt dass Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer die geringe Löhne hatten
die in Kurzarbeit gekommen sind
ergänzende Grundsicherung brauchen
deshalb meine Damen und Herren eine
verlässliche Absicherung so
unbürokratisch wie möglich ist das Ziel
dieser Reform es geht auch darum dass
wir dafür sorgen dass Menschen die in
dieser existenzielle Not geraten sind
sich nicht sorgen machen müssen dass sie
auch noch ihre Wohnung verlieren und wir
wollen auch dass es ein Frage des
Respekts vor Lebensleistung das kleines
Erspartes nicht angetastet werden muss
und hinzu kommt auch dass wir dafür
sorgen werden dass die Regelsätze gerade
in dieser Zeit angemessen angepasst
werden die Regelsätze beim Bürgergeld
werden nicht mehr der Inflation
hinterherlaufen meine Damen und Herren
das erste Ziel der Koalition an dieser
Stelle mit dem Bürgergeld ist also dafür
zu sorgen dass die Menschen die Hilfe
benötigen die auf existenzielle
Leistungen angewiesen sind die auch
bekommen das ist ein Sozialstaatsgebot
ein schutzversprechen unseres
Sozialstaates dass wir mit dem
Bürgergeld erneuern zweitens
zweitens und das ist mir noch wichtiger
es ist dafür zu sorgen dass wir nicht
nur existenzielle Not absichern sondern
dafür sorgen dass Menschen dauerhaft aus
der Not wieder herauskommen wir haben
eine Situation am Arbeitsmarkt die nicht
vergleichbar ist mit der von vor 20
Jahren als die hartz-iv-regeln
eingeführt wurden hatten wir
Massenarbeitslosigkeit in Deutschland
heute haben wir in vielen Bereichen
Arbeits- und Fachkräftemangel und ja wir
haben immer noch einen verfestigten
Sockel von Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit aber
wenn man sich anschaut woran das liegt
liegt es auch daran dass zwei Drittel
der Langzeitarbeitslosen Menschen keine
abgeschlossene Berufsausbildung haben
und das bisherige System führt dazu dass
sie dann hin und wieder mal in
Hilfstätigkeiten vermittelt werden das
Jobcenter sie aber oft nach einigen
Monaten oder Jahren wiedersieht wir
wollen den Menschen die Möglichkeit
schaffen ein Berufsabschluss nachzuholen
und wir sorgen dafür dass das auch
unterstützt und angereizt wird es geht
um dauerhafte Integration in
Arbeitsmarkt es geht um gute Arbeit
statt Hilfsjobs meine Damen und Herren
und wir haben uns dafür
ganz lange damit beschäftigt wie wir das
System besser machen wir haben mit dem
betroffenen Menschen gesprochen wir
haben mit den Kolleginnen und Kollegen
eine Jobcentern gesprochen die übrigens
eine großartige Arbeit machen wir haben
mit der Wissenschaft gesprochen
wir haben uns Systemen anderen Ländern
angeguckt und wir sind der festen
Überzeugungen dass Ausbildung statt
Aushilfsjobs dass die Einführung des
weiterbildungsgeldes der richtige Weg
ist und übrigens diese Integration in
den Arbeitsmarkt auch dafür sorgen wird
dass wir einen Beitrag zur Fachkräfte
Sicherung in Deutschland leisten meine
Damen und Herren in den letzten Tagen im
Vorfeld dieser ersten Lesung ist sehr
intensiv diskutiert worden schon das ist
auch in der Demokratie vollkommen in
Ordnung aber lassen sie sich eins ganz
deutlich sagen in diesen Zeiten in denen
der gesellschaftliche Zusammenhalt
bedroht ist finde ich es persönlich
unanständig dass es einige politische
Kräfte selbst im demokratischen Spektrum
gibt die versuchen
Geringverdiener gegen Bedürftige und
Bedürftige geflüchtete auszuspielen das
gehört sich nicht meine Damen und Herren
sie müssen die Gesellschaft für
Zusammenhalt
ja und das sage ich an die Adresse auch
der cdu/csu wir wollen als Koalition als
Ampelkoalition das arbeitssicher lohnt
das Arbeit ein Unterschied macht und das
ist der Grund warum wir dafür gesorgt
haben dass der Mindestlohn auf 12 Euro
erhöht wird wir haben da nicht
mitgemacht an dieser Stelle
das ist der Grund warum diese Koalition
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge für
Geringverdiener gesenkt hat das ist der
Grund warum wir das Kindergeld erhöhen
das ist der Grund warum wir die
Gaspreise unterbringen den
Kinderzuschlag erhöht haben den
steuerlichen Grundfreibetrag gemacht
haben arbeit muss sich lohnen wer
Vollzeit arbeitet muss von der Arbeit
leben können aber bedürftige Menschen
gegen Menschen mit geringem Einkommen
auszuspielen das ist kein Beitrag für
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt das
gehört sich nicht in diesem Land meine
Damen und
wir müssen in dieser gesellschaftlichen
Lage die gesamte Gesellschaft im Blick
haben und nicht Gruppen gegeneinander
ausspielen und deshalb nochmal das
Bürgergeld ist kein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen das Bürgergeld ist eine
existenzielle Sicherung für Menschen in
Not und ich will übrigens sagen die
Debatte auch darf auch nicht dazu führen
dass Menschen sich schämen die auf Hilfe
angewiesen sind die auch in Anspruch zu
nehmen das dürfen wir in Deutschland
auch nicht zu setzen
und dann wird ja einiges verbreitet ich
habe gelesen es seien bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen was für ein für nein das
ist es nicht das gibt einige die sich
das in Deutschland wünschen die
Koalition geht bewusst an anderen Weg
wir haben aber entschieden dass wir
einen Weg gehen indem wir nicht alle
Menschen die Not geraten sind und der
Generalverdacht stellen wollen zu faul
sein zu arbeiten das ist übrigens nicht
die Realität es gibt sehr sehr viele
Menschen ich habe mit vielen gesprochen
die unverschuldet in Not geraten sind
weil ihnen Schicksalsschlag
beispielsweise zwischengekommen sind es
gibt ganz hartnäckige Fälle in denen
braucht es Mitwirkungspflichten und
übrigens dann auch Leistungsminderungen
und die sind übrigens in dem Gesetz auch
vorgesehen bei akuten und wiederholten
meldeversäumnüssen und auch bei
dauerhaften Pflichtverletzungen aber ich
sage auch wir konzentrieren das Thema
Sanktionen auf die hartnäckigen Fälle
auf die es angewiesen sind der Geist des
Bürgergeldes meine Damen und Herren ist
ein anderer ist der Geist der Ermutigung
und der Befähigung und auch das leistet
einen Beitrag zum sozialen Zusammenhalt
und deshalb abschließend
die Einführung des Bürgergeldes zum
ersten Januar wird einer der größeren
Sozialreformen seit 20 Jahren sein und
ich bitte Sie mitzuhelfen dass wir das
auch schaffen denn es geht nicht nur um
die Menschen die auf Hilfe angewiesen
sind indem wir damit ein Stück das Leben
leichter machen wollen es geht um den
sozialen Zusammenhalt deshalb sage ich
das Bürgergeld das bedeutet
Grundsicherheit für unser ganzes Land
und deshalb bitte ich Sie um
Unterstützung herzlichen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
Bundesarbeitsminister Heil mit seiner
Vorstellung des
bürgergeldgesetzes welche Vorteile ist
seiner Meinung nach bringen soll wir
haben den Widerspruch aus den reinen
schon gehört insbesondere aus der
Unionsfraktion wir haben es ja im
Interview auch angesprochen mehr Kritik
dazu jetzt mutmaßlich von Stefan Stracke
aus der Unionsfraktion
Deutschland sucht händeringend nach
Arbeitskräften die Zahl der offenen
Stellen befindet sich auf einem Rekord
hoch bundesweit sind über 1,9 Millionen
Stellen unbesetzt egal wohin man blickt
in der Gastronomie in Einzelhandel im
Handwerk in der Industrie und
gleichzeitig suchen 2,4 Millionen
Arbeitslose eine Stelle
930.000 davon bereits seit Jahren
Aufgabe muss es jetzt sein die
Arbeitslosen deutlich besser als bisher
zu den offenen Stellen zu bringen wir
müssen alles dafür tun möglichst viele
Menschen dauerhaft den Arbeit zu bringen
das Bürgergeld wird dieser Aufgabe nicht
gerecht es ist eine verpasste Chance
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
Union wollen arbeitslose Menschen
möglichst rasch und dauerhaft in Arbeit
bringen dabei wollen wir das fordern
bewahren und das Fördern deutlich besser
machen die links-gelbe Koalition will
die Grundsicherung vor allem besser
ausstatten sie will mehr Leistung und
deutlich weniger Mitwirkungspflichten
und weniger Vermittlung in Arbeit das
geht vollkommen in die falsche Richtung
Union wollen dass die Hilfe des
Sozialstaats dienen zu Teil wird die
sich selbst nicht helfen können das ist
auch ein Gebot der Fairness gegenüber
den Steuerzahlern denn diese sind es ja
die mit ihren Steuermitteln die
Leistungen erst möglich machen und
gleichzeitig wollen wir die
Grundsicherung so weiterentwickeln dass
Leistung und Lebensleistung der
Hilfebedürftigen besser berücksichtigt
wird arbeit muss sich auch in der
Grundsicherung lohnen
die Links gelbe Koalition blendet dem
Gegenüber die Erwerbsbiographie und die
Lebensleistung von Menschen aus beim
Vermögen und beim Wohnen durch eine
zweijährige Karenzzeit das ist eine
eklatante Gerechtigkeitslücke auch da
geht das Bürgergeld in die falsche
Richtung meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren
wir wollen das Arbeitslose nicht zu
Langzeitarbeitslosen werden deshalb
müssen wir ab dem ersten Tag der
Arbeitslosigkeit alles dafür tun dass
die Hilfe überflüssig wird das
Arbeitsaufnahme gelingt und dazu braucht
es eine intensive Betreuung und Beratung
und passgenauer Unterstützung wir wollen
dazu ermutigen dass die Potenziale sich
entwickeln das neue Chancen mutig
ergriffen werden dass jede und jeden
geholfen wird einen Platz in der
Arbeitsgesellschaft zu finden damit
beruflicher Aufstieg und auch
gesellschaftliche Teilhabe besser
gelingen dazu braucht es Hilfe nicht nur
für den Betroffenen sondern für die
gesamte Familie Hilfe wie aus einer Hand
zusammen mit den Kommunen sorgt für
größere und nachhaltigere Erfolge und
die Jobcenter Mitarbeiter brauchen
endlich auch mehr Zeit um sich um den
einzelnen verstärkt kümmern zu können
würde am besten gelingen wenn man den
Betreuungsschlüssel verändert nichts von
all dem nichts von all dem wird in
diesem bürgergeldgesetz enthalten und
aufgegriffen das Bürgergeld ist hier
eine verpasste Chance bei der
Integration in Arbeit
und schlimmer noch
alle Erfahrungen zeigt dass besonders es
auf die ersten Monate in
Arbeitslosigkeit ankommt es sind die
wichtigsten Monate wenn man aus der
Arbeitslosigkeit in Arbeit kommen will
und statt besonders in den ersten
Monaten alles daran zu setzen um zu
aktivieren zu mobilisieren zu motivieren
ja notfalls auch mit bei
pflichtverstößen mit Leistungskürzungen
zur Antworten setzen Sie bei der Ampel
mit einer 6-monatigen Schonzeit sie
nennen das witzigerweise vertrauenszeit
genau das Entgegengesetzte Signal statt
Motivation setzen sie auf unverbindliche
Kooperation so kann der Weg aus Arbeit
nicht aus Arbeitslosigkeit nicht
gelingen
der Weg zurück in Arbeit wird deshalb
schwieriger weil die Ampel die
Vermittlung in Arbeit nicht verbessert
sondern sogar noch verschlechtert sie
kürzen die Mittel der Eingliederung nach
dem Haushaltsentwurf um 600 Millionen
Euro das bedeutet weniger Möglichkeiten
weniger Chance für Arbeitslose Fuß zu
fassen in Arbeit das ist schlicht fatal
was Sie an dieser Stelle machen
und statt zu kürzen wäre es viel
wichtiger mehr Mittel zur Verfügung zu
stellen denn die Flüchtlinge aus der
Ukraine brauchen jetzt unsere
Unterstützung die Mittelkürzung der
Ampel sind arbeitsmarktpolitisch falsch
und integrationsfeindlich noch dazu
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
sie sind die Regierung sie müssen ihre
eigenen Kürzungen verantworten Herr
Kollege und nicht hier auf die
Opposition verweisen wir wollen beim
fördern besser deutlich besser werden
und auf das fordern nicht verzichten zur
Wahrheit gehört ja dass über 95 Prozent
derer die sich in Arbeitslosigkeit
befinden mit pflichtverstößen mit
Sanktionen nichts zu tun haben weil sie
sich wie selbstverständlich an die
Regeln halten die linksgelbe Koalition
hat ja jetzt aktuell dafür gesorgt dass
wir im Kern ein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen haben und zwar bis Mitte
nächsten Jahres ja hören sie hören nur
zu das bedeutet das hat vier Empfänger
nach der aktuellen Rechtslage jedes
Arbeitsangebot ja scheint sie nur jeden
Integrationskurs jeden Deutschkurs jede
Weiterbildung folgenlos ablehnen können
es ist erstaunlich dass die
Arbeiterpartei SPD genau ein zwei
solches zustimmen ist noch erstaunlicher
dass die FDP dem zugestimmt hat diesen
sanktionsmoratorium
und jetzt wird denn mit dem Bürgergeld
eigentlich alles besser ich darf hier
mal zitieren aus einem Interview vom
Johannes Vogel vom 22 juli in
Deutschlandfunk zur Tat Zitat es muss
wie vor dem Bürgergeld die Möglichkeit
der Sanktionen geben in dem Ausmaß wie
das Verfassungsgericht das zulasst alles
andere ist unfair Zitat Ende und genau
das ist es nicht was sie in diesem
Bürgergeld Entwurf machen sie bleiben
weit dahinter zurück was das
Verfassungsgericht in diesem Bereich
zulässt das zeigt auch einmal sie bellen
und am Ende nicken sie ab sie als FDP
sie sind der Wackeldackel dieser
Koalition meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren
das Bürgergeld geht komplett in die
falsche Richtung es fordert nicht es
fördert nicht in die Maße wie es
notwendig ist und deswegen freue ich
mich auf die weiteren Beratungen weil
ich glaube dieses Gesetz kann nur besser
werden am besten mit einer Ablehnung und
vollkommen Neuaufsetzung dieses Gesetz
Stefan Strecke für die Unionsfraktion
mit einer sehr deutlichen Votum in
Richtung des bürgergeldgesetzes dass der
Bundesarbeitsminister hier zu Beginn
vorgestellt hat nämlich mit einer klaren
Ablehnung in dessen jetziger Form Beate
Müller Gemmeke aus der Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen ist die nächste Rednerin
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Minister Kollegin und
Kollegen sehr geehrte Gäste
vor drei Jahren habe ich hier gestanden
und habe darüber geredet was ich bei
Hartz IV und bei der Arbeitsförderung
alles ändern muss jetzt ist es soweit
das Bürgergeld kommt es ist gut dass wir
Hartz IV endlich überwinden
die Menschen brauchen natürlich soziale
Sicherheit wichtig ist vor allem aber
dass wir die Menschen die lange
arbeitslos sind unterstützen und stärken
sie brauchen neue Chancen und
Perspektiven und deshalb werden wir die
Beratung und die Arbeitsförderung anders
gestalten und genau dieser
Perspektivwechsel ist für uns beim
Bürgergeld besonders wichtig
Menschen sind Menschen sind aus ganz
unterschiedlichen Gründen
langzeitarbeitslos manche haben keine
Ausbildung andere haben gesundheitliche
Probleme und manchmal ist es einfach nur
das Alter auf diese unterschiedliche
Problemlagen aber hat Hartz IV heute
immer die gleiche Antwort und zwar die
Antwort heißt Aktivierung und genau
diese Logik diese verfehlte Logik werden
wir mit dem Bürgergeld verändern
und diesen und diesen Perspektivwechsel
möchte ich mit drei Punkten ganz kurz
verdeutlichen erstens wir schaffen
Augenhöhe und Vertrauen und Vertrauen
entsteht wenn die Zusammenarbeit in den
Jobcentern gut funktioniert und zwar
ohne dass jeder Brief gleich mit
Sanktionen droht und deshalb und deshalb
ersetzen wir die
Eingliederungsvereinbarung mit einem
kooperationsplan er wird gemeinsam
erarbeitet er ist niederschwellig er ist
verständlich er nimmt Rücksicht auf die
Vorstellung der Menschen denn nur wenn
die Erwerbslosen die
Integrationsschritte nachvollziehen
können wenn die Angebote für die
Menschen Sinn macht nur dann kann der
Weg in den Arbeitsmarkt zurück gelingen
zweitens
zweitens wir stellen Qualifizierung
Weiterbildung Ausbildung in den
Mittelpunkt und werden das auch
attraktiv machen und zwar mit einem
bürgergeldbonus und mit einem
zusätzlichen Weiterbildungsgeld in Höhe
von monatlich 150 Euro das ist uns ein
besonderes Anliegen denn Qualifizierung
ist Voraussetzung für eine nachhaltige
Integration in Arbeit
und drittens die Arbeits drittens treten
sie Arbeitsförderung muss tatsächlich zu
den Menschen passen bei manchen
Langzeitarbeitslosen funktioniert
Vermittlung andere brauchen zunächst
Qualifizierung und Weiterbildung und
wieder andere die brauchen erst einmal
geschützte Räume und soziale Teilhabe
und dieser Unterschiedlichkeit müssen
wir gerecht werden und zwar mit
individuellen Angeboten und deshalb
werden wir den vermittlungsvorgang
abschaffen und wir werden den sozialen
Arbeitsmarkt entfristen denn Arbeit
bedeutet soziale Kontakte Wertschätzung
Anerkennung und gesellschaftliche
Teilhabe das ist wichtig das ist wichtig
denn hier geht es um die Würde der
Menschen
langzeitarbeitslose Menschen sind lange
arbeitslos weil die Arbeitswelt nicht
inklusiv ist wenn nicht wenn die
Menschen nicht hundertprozentig passen
oder Unterstützung benötigen dann haben
sie häufig keine Chance und deswegen
hilft eben Aktivierung nicht und dabei
geht es eben auch nicht um die Kritik an
der Arbeit und am Engagement Engagement
der Beschäftigten in den Jobcentern
sondern es geht um die gesetzlichen
Grundlagen und die werden wir mit den
Bürgergeld
bürgergeldgesetz verändern und davon
werden die Langzeitarbeitslosen
profitieren aber davon bin ich
davon bin ich
davon bin ich zutiefst überzeugt denn
das Bürgergeld hat einen anderen einen
wertschätzenden Blick vielen Dank
nächste Rednerin für die afd-fraktion
Gerrit Huy
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
die afd-fraktion setzt den Bürgergeld
einen eigenen Antrag entgegen weil wir
nicht glauben dass das Bürgergeld
funktionieren wird es ist nichts anderes
als ein aufgeweichtes Hartz IV und das
hat schon nicht funktioniert so war es
beispielsweise nicht möglich aus dem
Millionen her der
hartz-iv-leistungsbezieher auch noch 100
oder 200 Personen für den
Koffertransport an deutschen Flughäfen
zu rekrutieren dabei sind und hören Sie
gut zu gut acht Prozent der Menschen
überwerbsfähigen Alter bei uns im Land
Hartz IV Empfänger das ist ein sehr
großer Anteil Menschen die von der
Arbeit der Steuerzahler Leben allein die
Krankenkosten für diese Gruppe einzig
ihre Familie betragen über 20 Milliarden
Euro im Jahr
in Dänemark Schweden oder Belgien
hingegen liegt der vergleichbare Anteil
bei gerade mal zwei Prozent also einem
Viertel da muss man sich schon fragen
was diese Länder besser machen
deswegen möchte ich mit Ihnen kurz
dorthin schauen allen Ländern ist gemein
dass schon Vermögen zunächst mal also
vor dem Schonvermögen das eigene Kapital
aufgebraucht werden muss und diese
chancevermögen liegen in der Regel unter
5000 Euro in jedem Fall deutlich unter
den deutschen 60.000 Euro und eine
angebotene Arbeit muss im Grundsatz auch
angenommen werden
in den Niederlanden muss man zudem aktiv
in der eigenen Wohngemeinde selbst
Arbeit suchen andernfalls bis zu drei
Stunden Fahrzeit Vortrag annehmen oder
man muss umziehen sonst wird die
Sozialhilfe gekürzt in Italien gibt es
das bürgereinkommen für Erwerbstätige
nur wenn man den letzten zwölf Monaten
seine Stelle nicht gekündigt hat und
auch kein anderes Familien Mitglied dies
getan hat sonst wird die Sozialhilfe
gekürzt in Frankreich werden beim Bezug
der Mindestsicherung Wohnungen Autos und
Schmuck gegengerechnet in Österreich
muss man seine Auto gleich verkaufen
wenn dies nicht für den Beruf benötigt
wird ein Arbeitsweg von insgesamt zwei
Stunden ist Zumutung zumutbar wäre
Schulungen nicht besucht eine
Wiedereingliederungsmaßnahme ablehnt
oder zu wenig Eigeninitiative zeigt
riskiert zwei Drittel der Leistungen
asylberüchtigte müssen zudem innerhalb
enger Fristen einen wertekurs und
Sprachkenntnisse auf a2-niveau
nachweisen und in der Schweiz
schließlich muss ich jeder
Leistungsempfänger zügig nach einer
neuen Arbeitsstelle umsehen und dafür
entsprechend Bewerbungen hinausschicken
bei Arbeit gefunden hat muss die
Sozialhilfe wieder zurückzahlen
unsere Nachbarn achten also streng
darauf dass Ihre Mindestsicherung nur
als vorübergehende Hilfe genutzt werden
kann dadurch sind sie wesentlich
erfolgreicher bei der Reintegration in
den Arbeitsmarkt nicht so bei uns in
mehr als der Hälfte der Fälle schaffen
es die Jobcenter nicht die
Arbeitschancen der Arbeitslosen zu
erhöhen sagt die interne Revision es
mangelt ihnen an Zeit und
Kontaktmöglichkeiten und nicht selten
auch an der Motivation der
Leistungsempfänger denn so sagt der
Sozialexperte bei huschen für Hartz IV
so wird er genannt für darf ich für
Hartz-IV-Bezieher mit Familie ist aber
rechnen kann da ist die Stütze zu hoch
sie haben mit Hartz IV deutlich mehr als
sie Einkommen aufgrund ihrer
Qualifikation beziehen würden
und auch
handwerkspräsident wollseifer fürchtet
bearbeitet ist zukünftig der Dumme meine
Damen und Herren wir wollen nicht dass
er Recht behält und deshalb unser Antrag
für eine aktivierende Grundsicherung die
Leistungsempfänger zügig wieder in
Arbeit vermittelt dankeschön
gerritui aus der afd-fraktion verweist
in ihrem Redebeitrag auch nochmal auf
den Antrag zum Thema Bürgergeld den die
AFD hier eingebracht hat nächster Redner
ist Jens vertriene aus der FDP-Fraktion
der ist ja Sprecher für Bürgergeld liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das Versprechen
unseres Sozialstaates ist es diejenigen
aufzufangen mit einem sozialen
Sicherungsnetz die nicht in der Lage
sind mehr für sich selbst sorgen zu
können dabei liegt die Betonung bewusst
auf können ein Sozialstaat dem es aber
nur darum geht finanzielle Bedürftigkeit
zu fordern ist nicht an sich sozial
sozial ist der erst wenn er auch
Menschen dabei unterstützt sich durch
eigene Arbeit heraus aus der sozialen
Bedürftigkeit befreien zu können das ist
aber kein Widerspruch Solidarität und
der Ansatz Menschen aus in den Arbeits
zu integrieren ist kein Widerspruch
sondern das gehört zu beiden zum
Grundsäulen des Sozialstaates
und gucken wir doch mal ins Gesetz rein
sie haben gesagt der Arbeits- und
Fachkräftemangel das wird das Bürgergeld
nicht vollkommen beseitigen können wir
haben so viel offene Stellen und auf der
anderen Seite so viele Menschen und
Arbeitslosigkeit Hartz IV hat das auch
nicht geschafft ihr System was die
verteidigen heute und was die so
beibehalten wollen was die nicht
verändern wollen hat dieses Problem auch
nicht gelöst
ein Beispiel wieso das nie gelöst wurde
sind die absurden Regelungen zu den
hinzuverdienstregelungen im
Hartz-IV-System wenn Menschen anfangen
mehr zu arbeiten die Motivation haben
sich Stück für Stück herauszuarbeiten
mit einem Job dann ist in die Regelungen
so dass Menschen die aufstocken zum Teil
ist weniger haben wenn sie mehr arbeiten
gehen der Anreiz ist genau falsch
herumgesetzt der Anreiz muss so sein
Menschen die mehr arbeiten haben auch
immer mehr in der Tasche und deswegen
passen wir diese hinzuverdienstregelung
ich weiß dass sie das im Kern ja sogar
teilen sie teilen ihre Form der
hinzuverdienstregelungen wir passen die
an ersten Schritt an oberhalb der
Minijobs wir wollen nicht dass Menschen
in Minijobs gefangen werden sondern dass
sie sich in
sozialversicherungspflichtige
Beschäftigung heraus aber und das werden
wir die hinzuverdienstregelungen genau
da anpassen dass ein Schritt der
Leistungsgerechtigkeit für unser Land
und die jungen Menschen die selbst in
der Bedarfsgemeinschaft aufwachsen die
dürfen in Zukunft wenn sie eine
Ausbildung machen wenn sie zur Schule
gehen ihre Nebenjob behalten es ist eine
absolute eine Absurdität der des
Leistungsprinzip das junge Menschen die
sich etwas hinzuverdienen dürfen davon
nichts haben es setzte der Hartz IV sagt
zu diesem jungen Menschen gehen nicht
arbeiten bleibt im System streng dich
nicht an und diese Botschaft kehren wir
um bei das setzt sich im Kopf von junger
Mensch und fest seine weitere wichtige
Änderung beim Bürgergeld und ich möchte
jetzt noch etwas sagen sie haben uns
dafür kritisiert für den Haushalt ich
habe mir noch mal die Anträge angeguckt
diese bei den letzten
Haushaltsberatungen gestellt haben zum
bmas-haushalt sie haben gefordert die
jugendberufsagenturen die Mittel dafür
zu halbieren die jungen Menschen die in
Arbeitslosigkeit sind den wollten sie
die Mittel Weg halbieren sie haben
gefordert die berufliche Integration und
Beratung von Zuwanderung in den
Arbeitsmarkt die Mitte zu halbieren sie
wollen nicht die ukrainischen
geflüchtete in den Arbeitsmarkt bringen
die wollten die Mittel halbieren sie
haben die fachkräfteoffensive im
Bundeshaushalt die Mitte wollten sie
ebenfalls halbieren tuen sie nicht so
als wenn sie Menschen in den
Arbeitsmarkt integrieren wenn das ihre
Haushaltspolitik ist das sind die Fakten
das waren ihre Anträge das sind nicht
unsere Anträge und wenn sie und wenn Sie
Herr Stracke und ich finde das richtig
und wir teilen das Gebot wir teilen doch
das Gebot dass derjenige der arbeiten
geht stets mehr haben muss als der der
nicht arbeiten muss da sind wir uns doch
einig sind sie aber in Kern wirklich
gegen die Regelsatzerhöhung Herr Stracke
sie haben auch gesagt dass die
Mehrleistungen vollkommen an der
Realität Vorbeigehen Herr witteka die
CDU-Politiker der gleich spricht hat bei
Twitter aber kommentiert nach dem
Koalitionsausschuss wo das beschlossen
wurde richtiger Impuls regulleistungen
zu erhöhen wenn die Inflation auch
massiv steigt muss gemacht werden ich
war mit Julia Klöckner bei Unter den
Linden ich ziehe die zitiere sie sie
können sich vielleicht erinnern wir sind
nicht gegen eine Regelsatzerhöhung davon
dann gehe ich aus dass die
Regelsatzerhöhung auf gut 500 Euro
kommen wird wenn wir sie nicht wenn wir
uns den hartz-iv-warenkorb angucken die
Lebensmittel um 17 Prozent steigen dann
ist es richtig den Regelsatz zu erinnern
es ist unredlich auf der einen Seite in
der öffentlichen Zeit zu sagen wir
wollen die Regelsätze erhöhen und auf
der anderen Seite mit den Ängsten der
Menschen in der Energiekrise das ist der
Grund wieso Menschen momentan das Gefühl
haben die vorher auf der Stelle
gestanden haben jetzt zurückfallen mit
diesem Gefühl zu spielen das ist der ist
Geschäft von Populisten ist eine Frage
der Krankheit in dieser Debatte bei den
Fakten zu bleiben und die Fakten sind
und das wissen sie sie werden ebenfalls
zu einer Inflationsanpassung sonst sagen
Sie es öffentlich dass sie dagegen sind
dass sie den Regelsatz bei 450 Euro
lassen wollen und zum Fakt gehört auch
die Sanktionen werden zum allergrößten
Teil beibehalten bis zu 30 Prozent kann
bei meldeversorgnis in sanktioniert
werden bei Pflichtverletzungen ist das
Maximum was das Bundesverfassungsgericht
zulässt und dann geht es um die
vertrauenszeit die sie kritisieren in
der vertrauenszeit können
meldeversäumnisse wenn jemand nicht für
einen Termin kommt ebenfalls
sanktioniert werden das sind 75% aller
Sanktionen das ist der Großteil der
Sanktionen der weiterhin auch in der
vertrauenszeit ausgesprochen wird
kritisieren sie uns dafür was wir machen
kritisieren sie das Bürgergeld aber
hören sie auf auf Grundlage falscher
Fakten in der öffentlichkeitsstimmung zu
machen es ist brandgefährlich es ist
brandgefährlich sie haben in
Niedersachsen das Ergebnis gesehen das
Ergebnis haben die in Niedersachsen
gesehen das Ergebnis ich dort es braucht
eine Oppositionspartei die die Regierung
treibt es braucht eine Oppositionspartei
der Mitte die uns kritisiert aber
kritisieren sie doch wirklich uns für
das was wir machen und erfinden sie
keine Fake News das ist gefährlich ob
Regelsatzerhöhung oder Sanktionen hören
sie auf mit diesem Geschäft hören sie
auf von sozial Tourismus zu sprechen ein
gefährliches Geschäft was sie machen
Jens flatrine der Sprecher für
Bürgergeld in der FDP-Fraktion mit
doch einem heftigen Angriff jetzt auf
die Unionsfraktion zuvor hatte auch
Widersprüche verwiesen zwischen der Rede
von Stefan Stracke hier im Parlament und
früheren Anträgen der Unionsfraktion und
da kriegt er jetzt viel Applaus für
diesen Redebeitrag aus dem Rhein der
ampelfraktion nächste Rednerin wird sein
Jessica Tati aus der Linksfraktion wo
sie Sprecherin für Arbeitsmarkt und
Sozialpolitik ist und da sie Treue
Zuhörer und Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
sind haben sie heute morgen schon bei
uns im Interview gesehen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Minister Heil
eines muss man ihnen lassen das ist das
erste Gesetz zur Änderung von Hartz IV
das nicht alles noch schlimmer macht
sondern einige Verbesserungen auf den
Weg bringen
das alle Leute die neuleistungen
beziehen eine zweijährige Karenzzeit
haben in der die Kosten für Wohnung und
Heizung voll übernommen werden das
unterstützen wir das hilft aber all
denen nicht die jetzt schon in Hartz IV
sind und die aus dem Regelsatz Monat für
Monat bei den Mietkosten draufzahlen
müssen eines der größten Probleme in
Hartz IV und diese Menschen die lassen
sie weiter im Regen stehen das müssen
sie doch jetzt ändern
gut ist dass Schüler Auszubildende und
Studenten zukünftig mehr vom selbst
verdienten Geld behalten dürfen endlich
setzen Sie damit die langjährige
Forderung von Sozialverbänden
Betroffenen und auch der Linken um
aber
dieses Gesetz ist keine Überwindung von
Hartz IV wie es ihr permanent behauptet
wird eine Überwindung von Hartz IV würde
zwingend mindestens drei Dinge erfordern
eine Geldleistung die für ein
bescheidenes aber angstfreies Leben
ausreicht das Recht auf aus- und
Weiterbildung um damit wieder am ersten
Arbeitsmarkt Fuß fassen zu können den
sozialen Arbeitsmarkt ausbauen für
diejenigen die ohne ihn keine Arbeit
finden können passiert das mit ihrem
Gesetz sorgen die 50 Euro für ein
angstfreies Leben nein sie fummeln
einfach so lange am Regelsatz herum bis
das rauskommt was der Minister wollte
das ist keine echte Erhöhung des
Regelsatzes sondern ein reiner
Inflationsausgleich der ist absolut
notwendig aber damit kommen sie
bestenfalls
bestenfalls ihrer Pflicht nach dass die
Leute noch essen kaufen können das in
der Strom nicht abgedreht wird und dass
sie im Winter nicht in einer dunklen
Wohnung sitzen müssen reichen 50 Euro
mehr die Wahrheit ist die Leute bleiben
genauso arm wie vorher denn das was sie
nicht angehen ist das jahrelange
kleintricksen der Regelsätze die Leute
standen doch schon vor den krassen
Preissteigerungen mit dem Rücken zur
Wand und deshalb fordern wir Sie auf
berechnen Sie die Regelsätze binnen
eines Jahres neu beteiligen sie die
Betroffenen beteiligen sie die
arbeitsloseninitiativen die
Wohlfahrtsverbände und die Tarifpartner
und bis das passiert ist braucht es
einen Zuschlag wir sagen monatlich 200
Euro mehr gegen die Inflation gegen
Armut und soziale Notlagen
jetzt zur Weiterbildung von Menschen in
Hartz IV sie reden da ja sehr viel
drüber vor allem wie unfassbar wichtig
Ihnen das wäre und was machen sie dann
sie kürzen eiskalt die Mittel dafür im
Bundeshaushalt was nutzen all ihre
schönen Worte wenn es kein Geld für die
Umsetzung gibt Menschen in Hartz IV
nehmen am allerwenigsten an
Weiterbildungen teil und das wissen sie
und trotzdem kürzen Sie einfach immer
weiter und wenn wir schon beim Kürzen
sind alle in der Ampel reden so stolz
vom sozialen Arbeitsmarkt wie
unverzichtbar wie erfolgreich und wie
großartig er noch sein oder stimmt auch
die geförderten Arbeitsplätze bringen
Menschen in Lohn und Brot mit
Arbeitgeber mit Arbeitsvertrag und mit
selbstverdientem Geld sie wollen den
sozialen Arbeitsmarkt mit diesem Gesetz
auf Dauer fortführen super Sache wir
unterstützen das bloß blöd das auch
dafür real fast keine Mittelmeer im
Haushalt sind und sie den sozialen
arbeitsmarktdefaktor kaputt sparen
korrigieren Sie das ansonsten ist das
die größte Verarsche auf dem Rücken von
Langzeitarbeitslosen sorry frau
Präsidentin Herr Minister dann müssen
Sie auch den Schneid haben sagen Sie
hier klipp und klar das
Langzeitarbeitslose keine Priorität mehr
für diese Bundesregierung haben wir
fordern 150.000 Jobs im sozialen
Arbeitsmarkt und die Finanzmittel die
dafür notwendig sind
sind im übrigen ihre 150.000 die sie in
der letzten Legislatur versprochen haben
Minister Heil unterm Strich mit diesem
Gesetzentwurf bleiben die Betroffenen so
arm und genauso im Abseits wie zuvor
Minister Heil damit bleibt ihr
Bürgergeld nach wie vor Hartz IV
ein Etikettenschwindel so möchte ich
jetzt mal formulieren and Jessica Tati
die Umwandlung von ALG2 von Hartz IV in
ein Bürgergeld denn auch das bleibe sagt
sie Hartz IV Dagmar Schmidt ist ein Pult
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
SPD-Fraktion
es sind schwierige Zeiten frau
Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen in
denen wir im Moment Verantwortung tragen
nur Energiepreise Inflation Sorgen um
die Zukunft
der Krieg Putins gegen Russland gegen
die Ukraine macht uns Angst und die
Auswirkungen spüren wir alle wir spüren
sie aber unterschiedlich hart die einen
nutzen diese Zeiten
um unsere Gesellschaft zu spalten um die
einen gegen die anderen auf den Platz zu
führen und um aus den berechtigten
Sorgen der Menschen ein populistisches
Süppchen zu kochen die anderen
übernehmen dieser Zeit Verantwortung für
das ganze Land
wir kümmern uns um diejenigen die Arbeit
haben und um diejenigen die keine haben
wir kümmern uns gerade um diejenigen die
arbeiten und trotzdem ein geringes
Einkommen haben wir haben deshalb den
Mindestlohn auf 12 Euro erhöht wer
Vollzeit arbeitet hat 280 Euro brutto
mehr und wir haben deshalb den
Übergangsbereich auf 2000 Euro
angehalten der 1250 Euro verdient hat 50
Euro mehr deshalb haben wir das
Kindergeld um 18 Euro den Kinderzuschlag
um 21 Euro erhöht und deswegen werden
wir das Wohngeld plus erhöhen das
Wohngeld damit deutlich um
durchschnittlich 190 Euro im Monat
erhöhen für 1,4 Millionen Menschen mehr
und wir werden
und wir werden mit der Gras und
wärmepreisbremse Last und Sorgen von den
Schultern nehmen wir schützen in diesen
schwierigen Zeiten diejenigen die keine
großen Reserven auf ihren Konten haben
die nicht jeden Monat etwas für die
schlechten Zeiten zurücklegen konnten
die sich anstrengen und für die es oft
trotzdem nicht reicht
und wir stützen diejenigen die keine
Arbeit haben indem wir Hartz IV
überwinden und das Bürgergeld schaffen
man kann der Ansicht sein dass es einen
niemals trifft
dass man die beste Geschäftsidee den
sichersten Job dass man selber resilient
gegen alle Schicksalsschläge ist dass
man eine Gesundheit hat wie Karl
Lauterbach dass man auf alle lesen
Lebensrisiken vorbereitet ist
in der echten Welt gilt das aber für die
allermeisten nicht das haben wir in der
Pandemie besonders gesehen gerade bei
den soloselbstständigen das gab es aber
auch schon vor vorher der spezialisierte
Akademiker dessen Spezialisierung nicht
mehr gefragt ist die Fachkraft mit Krebs
die Alleinerziehende mit Burnout und
deswegen ist es richtig dass wir Respekt
vor der Lebensleistung dieser Menschen
haben dass sie keine Angst haben sollen
gleich alles zu verlieren dass sie sich
darauf konzentrieren können
sich neu zu orientieren zu qualifizieren
einen Job statt einer Wohnung zu suchen
damit sie schnell wieder Anschluss
finden und einen guten Job
und wir wollen eine echte Perspektive
für diejenigen die nicht auf der
Sonnenseite groß geworden sind für
diejenigen die es aus der Bahn geworfen
hat die mit verschiedenen Problemen
gleichzeitig kämpfen die nicht die
Chance hatten eine gute Arbeit zu finden
und denen das Leben nicht so leicht
fällt wie anderen und es ist eine Frage
des Respekts und das machen wir nicht
von der Stange sondern individuell je
nach persönlicher Lage zu unterstützen
an den Stärken Möglichkeiten und
Vorstellungen der Arbeitslosen
anzusetzen genau damit es am Ende eben
auch Erfolg hat und es ist auch eine
Frage des Respekts etwas von den
Menschen zu erwarten dass sie mithelfen
dass sie mitwirken ihnen etwas
zuzutrauen und Ihnen als Partner auf dem
Weg zur Seite zu stehen deswegen ist es
nicht weniger als ein Paradigmenwechsel
den wir mit dem Bürgergeld einleiten
nicht die schnelle Vermittlung in
irgendeiner Arbeit eine nachhaltige
Vermittlung in gute Arbeit steht im
Vordergrund wenn nötig Qualifizierung
Ausbildung Coaching
nötig gesundheitliche und persönliche
Probleme wegräumen damit eben eine echte
Perspektive für die Menschen gelingt
und das ist nicht nur für den Einzelnen
wichtig lieber Stefan Stracke das ist
auch für die Gesellschaft insgesamt
richtig denn wenn Sie den Arbeitslosen
auch wenn sie es den arbeitslosen
Menschen nicht gönnen für unsere
Wirtschaft die dringend nach facht und
nicht nur nach Fach nach Arbeitskräften
sucht
ist es richtig für die ist es nämlich
wichtig dass wir Menschen befähigen
langfristig ihren Job zu machen nicht
Verbandsfunktionäre aber echte
Unternehmer die wollen keine
unmotivierte durch sanktionsdrohung
Androhung erfolgte Bewerbung auf dem
Tisch haben sie wollen sie wollen dass
die Menschen die sich bewerben die
kommen qualifiziert und motiviert sind
dass sie lesen und Schreiben gelernt
haben dort wo die Schule versagt hat
dass sie eine Ausbildung nachgeholt
haben dass sie Mut gefasst haben und am
Abend stolz auf das sind was sie leisten
und der soziale Arbeitsmarkt den wir
entfristen hat uns gezeigt dass es genau
so gehen kann
ich bin stolz dass wir heute in erster
Lesung des Bürgergeld in das Parlament
einbringen darauf dass wir in der
Ampelkoalition gemeinsam schaffen was
vorher nicht möglich war eine
Grundsicherung die kein Stigma sondern
Schutz und Hilfe für ein
selbstbestimmtes lebenseinbild ich freue
mich auf die Diskussion
sagt Dagmar Schmidt stellvertretende
Vorsitzende der SPD-Fraktion in dieser
ersten Beratung eines Gesetzentwurfs der
Bundesregierung zum Bürgergeld das ja
bekanntermaßen Hartz IV ablösen soll wie
es aus SPD-Kreisen schon länger heißt
das Hartz IV überwinden soll da haben
einige ihre Zweifel insbesondere aus der
Opposition natürlich und dazu hören wir
jetzt Kai Whittaker aus der
Unionsfraktion Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Kollege Stracke
hat ja recht wenn er sagt auf der einen
Seite haben wir fast zwei Millionen
offene Stellen und auf der anderen Seite
fast über zwei Millionen Menschen ohne
Job wann also wenn ich jetzt wäre der
beste Moment um möglichst viele
Arbeitssuchende wieder in den
Arbeitsmarkt zu bringen
denn Herr teutrine in unseren 16 Jahren
haben wir es geschafft mit Hartz IV die
Anzahl der Arbeitslosen zu halbieren das
ist die Benchmark an der sie sich noch
messen lassen müssen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen von der FDP und genau diese
Chance lässt es Bürgergeld im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes links liegen man
erkennt es ja schon an ihrem
gesetzestitel es geht ihnen fast
ausschließlich ums Geld und erholt Rede
wenn Sie nicht wollen dass Fake News
verbreitet werden dann tun sie das auch
bitte nicht wir haben überhaupt kein
Problem damit wenn die Hartz-IV-Sätze
sich in der Inflation erhöhen um 50 Euro
aber es geht um das was sie es drumherum
machen denn sie wollen nämlich nicht
mehr prüfen ob jemand die Leistung
überhaupt noch wirklich braucht es
interessiert sie nicht mehr ob jemand
noch angemessen heizt es ist ihnen egal
ob es Leute gibt die hartnäckig gegen
alle Regeln verstoßen das ist respektlos
es ist respektlos gegenüber den
überwältigende Mehrheit von
Arbeitssuchenden die sich an die Regeln
halten und alles dafür tun wie dein
Arbeit zu kommen und es ist respektlos
gegenüber allen die mit ihren Steuern
unseren Sozialstaat finanzieren die SPD
nannte sich einst Arbeiterpartei aber
mit diesem Gesetz geben sie gerade die
Leute auf die etwas mehr als Hartz IV
verdient und mit ihren Steuern auch
unseren Sozialstaat finanzieren
[Applaus]
dazu hängen und stattdessen Bürgergeld
beantragen arbeit muss sich immer lohnen
wenn das nicht mehr gilt gefährden Sie
den sozialen Frieden in unserem Land
und ihr
Verweisung gestatten Sie einen
Zwischenfrage aus der Fraktion
auch der Fraktion der Bündnis 90 Grün
der Herr audresch glaube ich ne
sehr gerne
Herr wittiger
offensichtlich Herr audritsch hat das
Wort
also wenn ich ihn antworten soll muss es
ein bisschen leiser sein weil ich kann
den Ärger verstehen aber tatsächlich ist
glaube ich eine konkrete Frage
das was man ihnen stellen muss also das
was ich hier tun offensichtlich tun ist
erneut die Schiene in Angriff zu nehmen
die wir in den letzten Wochen und
Monaten gesehen haben dass sie
tatsächlich Fake News verbreiten dass
sie tatsächlich einfach Lügen in die
Welt setzen und das ist das was wir
gesehen haben zum Thema
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen das ist
das was sie wieder insiniert haben
gerade es ist kein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen das gleiche ist beim
sozialtourismusvorwurf dass es
Rechtspopulismus in Reinsdorf Form der
da vorgebracht wird und da wo sie sich
aus wo sich aus der Debatte Kegeln und
ganz rechts ganz rechts bei der AFD
anbiedern das ist das was sie machen
deswegen möchte ich Sie fragen warum
haben sie im Ausschuss ganz dezidiert
gefordert dass Inflationsanpassung
geschehen muss warum haben sie gefordert
dass mehr Anpassung geschehen muss warum
sieht man das in Tweets von ihnen warum
kommt all das und gleichzeitig auf der
anderen Seite dann die Hetze die sie
verbreiten warum sagen Sie auf der einen
Seite warum sagen Sie auf der einen
Seite das sei
dass das sei ein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen woher kommt das es gibt
keinen Punkt an dem man festmachen kann
dass es ein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen ist sie tun das und noch
einmal zum zum Regelsatz das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat 2014 gesagt
dass man auch unter der Unterschrift
kommen Sie zum warum stellen sie sich
gegen das Bundesverfassungsgericht auch
das ist eine Frage die Sie beantworten
müssen und zuletzt letzte Frage wenn
ihnen die Menschen die Niedriglohnsektor
unterwegs sind wirklich von wert sind
warum hat ihre ganze Partei ihre
Fraktion
Mindestlohn enthalten warum haben sie
sich nicht bitte zum Schluss von ihnen
an der Stelle enthalten haben sie sich
weil sie keine Position haben und nur
eins tun Fake News und Hetze verbreiten
das ist das was sie tun
sie dürfen Antworten
also
ist ja ist ja interessant zu sehen was
passiert wenn man keine redezahl von
seiner Fraktion zu gestattet bekommt
Herr outrecht nur weil ihnen Kritik
unlieb ist
ist das noch lange keine Hetze und ich
finde es gefährlich ich finde es
gefährlich unter DemokratInnen und
Demokraten und wir als Christdemokraten
und Christ soziale sind stolze
DemokratInnen und Demokraten die dieses
Land 70 Jahre lang geprägt haben
uns in eine Ecke zu stellen wo sie
wissen dass wir definitiv nicht
hingehören und damit sich versuchen sich
versuchen
leidiger Kritik zu entledigen das lassen
wir Ihnen nicht durchgehen nicht bei
diesem Gesetz und bei allen anderen
Debatten auch nicht ist ein gefährliches
Spiel was übertreibt
und deshalb Herr Minister möchte ich
auch auf ihren Verweis zurückkommen man
dürfe Arbeitslose nicht gegen
Niedrigverdiener ausspielen ist
vollkommen richtig aber man kann eben
wie ich gerade eben gesagt habe
berechtigte Kritik nicht einfach vom
Tisch wischen nur weil sie in unangenehm
ist und dann sie müssen schon dafür
sorgen dass auch die Niedrigverdiener
etwas haben und da können sie ja mal
anfangen dafür zu sorgen dass es mehr
Netto vom Brutto übrig bleibt
stattdessen erhöhen Sie jetzt die
Krankenkassenbeiträge und das in Zeiten
in der Stadt an steigenden Preisen
sowieso mit verdient dass es ungehörig
und das allerwichtigste wäre doch jetzt
die Menschen in Arbeit zu vermitteln
anstatt sie im System zu verwalten und
dazu fällt ihnen ja fast nichts ein wir
wissen aus der Forschung je besser sie
sich um die Menschen kümmern je
schneller sie sich kümmern desto eher
gelingt der Sprung in Arbeit das heißt
mehr Personal bessere Betreuung das wäre
jetzt wichtig und diese
nur dieser Erkenntnis Folgen ja gar
keine Taten stattdessen streichen Sie
600 Millionen Euro für den
Eingliederungstitel sie kürzen noch
einmal bei der Verwaltung um 50
Millionen letztes Jahr haben sie schon
um 750 Millionen gestrichen sie machen
das glatte Gegenteil und es ist sogar
noch schlimmer in den ersten sechs
Monaten wollen Sie sich in Zukunft so
gar nicht mehr mit den Arbeitssuchenden
Menschen kümmern dabei wissen wir je
schneller sie sich kümmern desto
schwerer wird es wieder je länger sie
sich damit Zeit lassen desto schwerer
wird es wieder herauszukommen und ich
weiß dass sie den Leuten etwas Gutes tun
wollen aber in Wahrheit schaden sie
ihnen das ist respektlos gegenüber die
Menschen die schon zu lange ohne Arbeit
sind und es ist auch respektlos
gegenüber den Mitarbeitern in den
Jobcentern sie versprechen den Leuten ab
jetzt eine Behandlung auf Augenhöhe das
war schon immer richtig es wird jetzt
aber noch schwieriger wenn Sie den
Jobcenter Mitarbeitern gleichzeitig die
Mittel kürzen und was mich an den
Begriff der Augenhöhe besonders stört
ist doch folgendes sie unterstellen dass
in den Jobcentern die Würde der Menschen
missachtet wird das ist was sie tun und
das kann man in ihrem Gesetzentwurf auch
lesen sie legen minutiös fest was der
Jobcenter Mitarbeiter während der
vertrauens- und kooperationszeit alles
nicht darf in Zukunft müssen sich die
Mitarbeiter mehr um § als um die
Menschen kümmern werte Kolleginnen
Politiker entschuldigung dass ich sie
nochmal unterbrechen muss aber es gibt
noch eine Zwischenfrage von Frau
müller-gemecke aus der Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen ich würde ich würde
vorschlagen dass das Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die schon geredet haben nicht
unbedingt noch eine Zwischenfrage
werte Kolleginnen und Kollegen bei
diesem Bürgergeld stehen nicht die
Menschen im Mittelpunkt sondern die
hartz-iv-vergangenheitsbewältigung der
SPD sie wollen die Menschen ruhigstellen
anstatt sie zu aktivieren um ihr
Gewissen zu beruhigen das hat kein
Arbeitsloser verdient wir als Union
sagen stattdessen wir erhalten am
fordern fest und müssen beim fördern
noch besser werden durch wenige
Bürokratie damit die Mitarbeiter mehr
Zeit für die Arbeitssuchenden Menschen
haben denn Hartz IV überwindet man nicht
durch einen neuen Namen Hartz IV
überwindet man durch Taten indem man die
Leute in Arbeit bringen fangen Sie
endlich damit an
aus der Unionsfraktion in einer Debatte
die phasenweise emotional ist
phasenweise auch polemisch schwer hatten
eben einen Zwischenfrage von Andreas
audresch aus der Fraktion die Grünen die
hier einige Wellen geschlagen hat
Auseinandersetzung hier im Plenum
sollten wir alle darauf achten nicht uns
gegenseitig Hetzerei vorzuwerfen
das gilt
für alle Seiten
das ist nicht neu aber wir haben
sie können mich jederzeit daran erinnern
weil ich werde auch in Zukunft daran
erinnern wir haben draußen in der
Bevölkerung wahrlich schwierige Zeiten
das hat hier fast jeder Redner gesagt
und es spielt eine große Rolle wie wir
hier in diesem Hause auch miteinander
diskutieren und das ist jetzt von meiner
Seite mal eine Appell
zum heutigen Tage vielleicht auch für
zukünftige Debatten damit will ich keine
emotionalen Debatten unterbinden auf
keinen Fall das muss in der Sache sein
wir müssen das auch alle miteinander
aushalten aber es ist glaube ich für die
die uns hier zuschauen und zuhören auch
wichtig dass es um die Inhalte geht und
dass wir uns nicht gegenseitig hier im
Hause als Abgeordnete beschimpfen
jetzt
mit diesem Aufruf
komme ich zur nächsten Rednerin der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen Stefanie
Effner
wir haben doch ein bisschen Zeit bis das
Pult runterfährt
sie haben das Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Gäste ich möchte in
der Debatte gern zu den Menschen
zurückkehren um die es hier geht die
arbeitslosen Menschen in diesem Land
aber auch all die Menschen die heute
Arbeit haben und denen es genauso
passieren kann ihre Arbeit zu verlieren
als Hartz IV eingeführt wurde war ich in
den Entzügen meines Studiums der
Sozialen Arbeit ich habe mich auch für
den Weg in Berufspolitik entschieden
weil ich in der Beratung immer wieder
Situationen erlebt habe wo ich mit der
bestehenden Rechtslage Menschen nicht
helfen konnte
umso mehr freue ich mich dass wir mit
der Einbringung des bürgergeldgesetzes
eine der größten sozialpolitischen
Reformen seit 20 Jahren auf den Weg
bringen
wir sind mit dem Versprechen angetreten
Hartz IV zu überwinden und ich finde wir
sind auf einem guten Weg dahin wir
Leuten eine neue Zeit ein wir schaffen
die Voraussetzung für eine Kommunikation
auf Augenhöhe in den Job sondern und
sorgen für ein Ende der Stigmatisierung
von bedürftigen Menschen wir geben
Menschen wieder mehr Vertrauen in
unseren Sozialstaat in der zweijährigen
Karenzzeit werden die Kosten für Wohnung
und Unterkunft in tatsächliche Höhe
übernommen deutlich mehr Erspartes darf
behalten werden damit nehmen wir den
Menschen in dieser ohnehin schwierigen
Situationen die Angst nicht nur ihren
Job sondern auch noch ihr zu Hause und
ihre kompletten Rücklagen zu verlieren
sie können sich genau damit auf eine
Weiterbildung oder die Suche nach einer
neuen Arbeit konzentrieren und die
Jobcenter entlasten wir so auch Sie
können sich nämlich um Unterstützung
kümmern anstatt Verwaltung und
Bürokratie wir Grüne haben lange für die
Abschaffung von Sanktionen gekämpft sie
werden nun deutlich entschärft
Leistungen können maximal um 30 Prozent
gekürzt werden härtere Sanktionen für
unter 25-jährige werden abgeschafft und
vor allem entfallen die anlasslosen
sanktionsandrohungen in jedem schreiben
die allermeisten Menschen 97 Prozent
kooperieren völlig problemlos und genau
die werden damit nicht mehr mit
Sanktionen bedroht das ist ein
denn es ist wissenschaftlich belegt dass
Sanktionen nicht dazu führen dass
Menschen schneller eine Arbeit aufnehmen
im Gegenteil
langfristig schaden sie einer
dauerhaften
Arbeitsmarktintegration sie sorgen nur
für kurzfristige Arbeitsaufnahme und was
hier geschieht ist nichts weniger als
ein Paradigmenwechsel hin zu mehr
Anerkennung zutrauen und Befähigung auch
bei jungen Menschen sorgen wir für mehr
Chancengerechtigkeit indem wir die ihnen
Zuverdienstmöglichkeiten für
SchülerInnen und Studierende anheben
damit können Sie endlich selber etwas
ansparen das sorgt für bessere
Startbedingungen in das Berufsleben und
Erfolgserlebnisse wir machen Schluss mit
der Zwangsverrentung durch die ältere
ArbeitnehmerInnen bisher viel zu oft aus
dem Berufsleben gedrängt wurden
nicht mehr im gesamten Rentenbezug mit
den finanziellen Einbußen Leben denn sie
verdienen ebenso Chancen und Anerkennung
und wir alle können gerade in Zeiten des
Fachkräftemangels nicht auf diese
Fähigkeiten verzichten mit einem
zusätzlichen Rechenschritt
passen wir den Regelsatz deutlich besser
an die Inflation an und erhöhen ihn
stärker als bisher es ist kein Geheimnis
dass wir Grüne uns an dieser Stelle mehr
gewünscht hätten dennoch haben wir eine
entscheidende Verbesserung an dieser
Stelle erreicht mich
ärgert die andauernde Kritik dass ich
mit der bürgergeldreform Arbeit nicht
mehr lohnen würde wegen nur höherer
Regelsätze wird niemand seinen Job
aufgeben und sich in die soziale
Hängematte legen wollen
wer ehrlich in sich selber hineinhört
spürt eines ganz genau die Vorstellung
den eigenen Job zu verlieren macht Angst
Angst vor Abstieg Angst den eigenen
Kindern nichts mehr bieten zu können
Angst nicht mehr dazu zu gehören Angst
davor Bittsteller bei Behörden zu sein
gegen diese Angst setzen wir das
Versprechen der bestmöglichen
Unterstützung um aus dieser Situation
herauszukommen wir haben im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart dass wir
mit unserer Reform die würde achten und
gesellschaftliche Teilhabe ermöglichen
an manchen Punkten liegen noch Aufgaben
vor uns beispielsweise müssen wir auch
die Mensch auf die Menschen im
Sozialhilfe Bezug zu schauen niemand
sucht sich eine Erwerbsminderung wegen
einer Erkrankung aus auch diesen
Menschen müssen wir die Anerkennung
entgegenbringen die sie verdienen ich
freue mich auf die anstehenden Beratung
[Applaus]
ich glaube das Puls muss noch etwas
höher
nächster Redner für die afd-fraktion
Norbert Kleinwächter
[Applaus]
werte Frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das Bürgergeld
ist unsozial denn es übervorteil
diejenigen die nicht arbeiten gegenüber
denjenigen die jeden Tag den Wohlstand
in unserem Land erwirtschaften meine
Damen und Herren und ich muss schon
sagen ich finde die Debatte wirklich ein
bisschen zynisch die hier geführt worden
ist wo windelbegriffe fallen
Chancengleichheit Augenhöhe
vertrauenszeit kooperationszeit meine
Damen und Herren während die
altenpflegerhelferinnen die jeden Tag
auf die Arbeit geht nicht mehr weiß wie
sie mit ihrer Tochter noch durch durch
den Winter kommen soll weil sie die
Wohnung gar nicht mehr beheizen kann das
ist doch die Realität in Deutschland und
an dieser Realität geht diese Debatte
vollkommen vorbei meine Damen und Herren
sie ersetzen Leistung durch Müßiggang
dabei war es gerade das Leistungsprinzip
was unsere Gesellschaftsmodell des
Sozialen Marktwirtschaft doch immer
erfolgreich gemacht hat wir haben
verlangt Leute qualifiziert euch strengt
euch an stellt eure Arbeitskraft zur
Verfügung und damit können wir Frieden
Wohlstand Demokratie und ja auch ein
sozialhilfesystem aufbauen das
funktioniert und dass allen in echter
Not hilft aber sie sie heben das
Leistungsprinzip völlig auf und erheben
den Müßiggang zum neuen Prinzip die
implizite Frage die sie mit dem
Bürgergeld doch stellen ist warum bist
du so blöd und arbeitest eigentlich noch
und damit Frau Effner heben Sie nicht
das stigmaderer auf die im
sozialleistungsbezug sind sondern sie
stignomatisieren alle die da
unfreiwillig hereinfallen noch umso mehr
und das ist das dramatische daran
machen wir doch mal die Rechnung auf
allein mathematisch lohnt es sich doch
kaum mehr zu arbeiten für jemanden der
wenig verdient ein Vollzeit arbeitender
mindestlohnempfänger nach dem
neuen machen 80 Euro brutto 1404 Euro
netto der wird locker eingeholt von
einem bürgergeldbezieher mit 5002 Euro
Regelsatz Plus und das ist der
springende Punkt die Übernahme
sämtlicher Wohn- und Heizkosten egal ob
die angemessen sind egal in welcher Höhe
weil sie nämlich die Karenzzeit
eingeführt haben das bedeutet während
der normale Arbeitnehmer seine Wohnung
nicht mehr heizen kann kann der
bürgergeld-empfänger der 130
Quadratmeter Altbauwohnung in
Charlottenburg beheizen oder sein
Einfamilienhaus in Tegernsee das ist
genau das was Sie hier einführen und das
ist ungerecht meine Damen und Herren
während jeder normale Arbeitnehmer in
der Früh einstempeln am Abend Auschecken
muss erlauben sie den Bürgergeld
Empfängern eine Ortsabwesenheit sogar im
Ausland meine Damen und Herren und
während ein Lkw-Fahrer seinen
Führerschein sogar sein privaten
riskiert bei einem Fehlverhalten einen
selbstständiger sein Haus weil sein
Betrieb zum Beispiel auch aufgrund ihrer
Politik pleite geht ein fassadenreiniger
oder Fabrikarbeiter sein Leben bei einem
Betriebsunfall was riskiert der
bürgergeldempfänger wenn er vor die
Jobcenter Mitarbeiterin mit einem fetten
Grinsen tritt und sagt ich habe jetzt
aber keinen Bock er riskiert gar nichts
denn wir haben ja vertrauenszeit wir
haben ja Kooperation wir erheben ja
sämtliche Sanktionen auf und das ist
genau der falsche Weg das ist das
falsche Signal an die Öffentlichkeit
meine Damen und Herren wir dürfen nicht
den Müßiggang etablieren und das dann
bedingungslose Grundeinkommen was er
mich genau in diesem Moment vor der
Jobcenter Mitarbeiterin zum
bedingungslosen Grund sein wird sondern
wir müssen Leistung wieder fördern und
deswegen fordern wir ja die aktivierende
Grundsicherung dass wir sagen lasst die
Leute nie aus dem Arbeitsmarkt
herausfallen sondern spätestens sechs
Monate nach dem Eintritt in den
sozialleistungsbezug 15 Wochenstunden
Bürgerarbeit machen das ist
gemeinnützige Arbeit die uns alle
voranbringt und die Leute verlernen es
nie sich zu organisieren pünktlich
aufzustehen auf Arbeit zu gehen haben
wir den Mut diejenigen wirklich und zwar
mit reinen Sachleistungen zu
sanktionieren die unser
sozialleistungssystem nicht brauchen
sondern benutzen Frau Effner und lassen
Sie uns auch sicherstellen dass die
Leute wenigstens anwesend sind wenn sie
schon Sozialleistungen beziehen und ihre
Arbeitskraft zur Verfügung stellen
können wir brauchen keinen
sozialbezugssystem wir brauchen ein
sozialleistungssystem und das ist der
Unterschied
Norbert Kleinwächter und seine
Rechnungen der finanziellen Vorteile von
bürgergeldbeziehern gegenüber
arbeitenden auch mit geringem Einkommen
das wird von mindestens zwei Studien
nicht bestätigt
nächster Redner jetzt ist Pascal Kober
aus der FDP-Fraktion Sprecher für
Arbeitsmarkt und Sozialpolitik
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
mit unserem Gesetzentwurf werden wir in
Zukunft auch Grundkompetenzen fördern
Grundkompetenzen wie Lesen Schreiben und
Rechnen und da komme ich drauf weil es
gibt auch im Laufe dieser Debatte doch
den Verdacht dass es auch
Grundkompetenzen der positionsarbeit
geben müsste und dazu gehört
beispielsweise
auch
die Fähigkeit oder zumindestens der
Wille auch mal zu lesen was als
Gesetzentwurf vorliegt und nicht im
wilden Nebel von Behauptungen
herumzustochen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen so behaupten sie dass nicht
mehr geprüft würde ob jemand
anspruchsberechtigt ist für Leistungen
von hartz-iv- künftig Bürgergeld das ist
Grund falsch sie kennen offensichtlich
nicht den Unterschied zwischen
Einkommensprüfung und vermögensprüfung
und ich will Ihnen mal was sagen wenn
sie als Freiberufler als Selbstständiger
sich ein Leben lang gearbeitet haben was
aufgebaut haben und dann aufgrund einer
wirtschaftlichen Situation wie
beispielsweise Corona in Hartz IV
rutschen weil das das Letzte ist was
diese Sozialstaat dann für Sie bereit
hält und sie aufhängen und sie dann
sagen die sollen aber erstmal die Haus
verkaufen dann zeigt das was sie von der
Lebensleistung dieser Menschen halten
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und zur Grundkompetenzen gehört auch
dass man bestimmte wirtschaftliche und
gesetzgeberische Zusammenhänge kennt und
aufeinander beziehen kann Herr
wittdecker sie behaupten sie hätten die
Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit halbiert ja mit
welchem Gesetz denn sie haben ein Hartz
IV in ihrer Regierungszeit in 16 Jahren
so gut wie nichts geändert und jetzt
rühmen sie sich dessen dass sie jetzt
jetzt rühmen Sie sich dass Sie jetzt
rühmen Sie sich dass Sie die
Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit
halbiert hätten die Wahrheit ist sie
haben es nicht geschafft von der
verhärteten Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit
runterzukommen sie haben es nie
geschafft sie dauerhaft unter 700.000 zu
bringen und das ist genau der Anspruch
den wir jetzt realisieren wollen und
darauf sollten Sie eigentlich auch mit
guten Vorschlägen reagieren und nicht
mit falschen zusammenhängen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist
wichtig Stefan Stracke absolut wichtig
dass wir Menschen nachhaltig in Arbeit
vermitteln aber genau daran hat Hartz IV
eben in der Vergangenheit gekrankt wir
müssen es schaffen dass Menschen nicht
nur kurzfristig vermittelt werden und
deshalb schaffen wir zum Beispiel den
vermittlungsvorrang ab ich suche
übrigens nach wie vor nach ihren
besseren Vorschlägen der Minister hat im
Frühsommer seine Vorschläge mündlich
mitgeteilt im Sommer ist dieser
Gesetzentwurf erarbeitet worden von der
Koalition es wäre auch ein eine Weise
der Leistungsgerechtigkeit liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Opposition
wenn sie es geschafft hätten in den
Wochen und Monaten selber einen
Vorschlag vorzulegen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
bevor Sie also von Müßiggang oder
ähnlichen Begriffen im Zusammenhang von
Leistungsbeziehern sprechen machen sie
selber ihre Arbeit beteiligen sich
konstruktiv an der
Opposition und an der parlamentarischen
Arbeit das würde uns alle voranbringen
vielen Dank
Pascal Kober war das für die
FDP-Fraktion und wir haben hier mal eine
kleine Statistik aufgemachte weil es ein
uns ein klein wenig aufgefallen ist zehn
Redner haben wir hier bislang gehabt
außerdem Bundesminister und fünf davon
sind aus Baden-Württemberg gekommen
jetzt ist ein Pult Annika Klose für die
SPD-Fraktion und die kommt aus Berlin
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Kollegin
sehr geehrte Zuschauerin
mehr Respekt mehr Chancen mehr
Sicherheit eine soziale Politik für
dieses Land das bedeutet das neue
Bürgergeld dass wir hier heute
diskutieren
das Bürgergeld ist eine grundlegende
Reform unserer sozialen
Sicherungssysteme gerade deswegen ist es
wichtig dass die Menschen in diesem Land
darüber Bescheid wissen was geplant ist
und so worauf sie sich einstellen können
doch auch in dieser Debatte wird von
verschiedenen Seiten mal wieder gezielt
müssen Informationen verbreitet deswegen
möchte ich die Gelegenheit jetzt mal
nutzen ein paar Thesen hier nochmal
aufzuräumen erstens die AFD behauptet
dass Bürgergeld sei ein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen das stimmt nicht ein
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen ist eine
Geldsumme die ohne Vorbedingungen an
alle BewohnerInnen eines Landes
ausgezahlt wird das viel Geld steht zwar
grundsätzlich allen Menschen in
Deutschland zu aber es ist an
Bedingungen geknüpft das Bürgergeld wird
an Menschen ausgezahlt die ihren
Lebensunterhalt nicht aus eigener Kraft
bestreiten können beispielsweise weil
sie arbeitslos sind oder weil sie nicht
arbeiten können dafür muss ein Antrag
gestellt werden und der wird überprüft
klar ist wer Hilfe braucht soll diese
auch bekommen und zwar möglichst einfach
und unbürokratisch deswegen vereinfachen
wir ja auch den Antrag und führen eine
Karenzzeit von zwei Jahren ein so dass
man nicht direkt auch noch die Wohnung
und das zurückgelegte fürs Alter
verliert wenn man gerade auch schon
seinen Job verloren hat
klar ist aber auch
das auch Menschen die das Bürgergeld
Geld bekommen damit dem Jobcenter
zusammenarbeiten müssen gemeinsam wird
dann geschaut dass die Menschen
möglichst gut dabei unterstützt werden
um wieder auf die eigenen Beine zu
kommen dabei muss man mitmachen das
heißt Mitwirkungspflichten es gibt also
Bedingungen die man erfüllen muss um das
Bürgergeld zu bekommen und entsprechend
ist es kein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen
eine weitere verbreitete Annahme ist
zweitens dass das Bürgergeld eine reine
Umbenennung von Hartz IV sei quasi hat
wir mit einem Anstrich auch das ist
nicht richtig das Bürgergeld bedeutet
einen echten Kulturwandel im Umgang mit
dem Menschen im Leistungsbezug mit dem
bürgergeldgesetz wollen wir dafür sorgen
dass den Menschen die Unterstützung
brauchen nachhaltig geholfen wird um
wieder auf die eigenen Beine zu kommen
es geht darum die Menschen da abzuholen
wo sie sind und mit guter Beratung
passgenauer Qualifizierung und
individuellen Lösungen eine langfristige
Perspektive auf dem Arbeitsmarkt zu
schaffen und das ist keineswegs so wie
die AFD und die Union gerne behaupten
dass die Menschen der Grundsicherung
grundsätzlich nicht arbeiten wollen
würden oder faul sein faul und wenn man
bloß die Leistung genug runterkürzt das
dann plötzlich alle in Arbeit sein den
Eindruck bekommt man ja wenn man ihn so
zuhört das ist nicht nur ein absolut
absurdes Menschenbild dass ihr dann den
Tag liegen legen sondern es entspricht
auch völlig der re darum geht die
Übergröße Mehrheit der Menschen die
länger als ein Jahr arbeitslos sind
haben zum Beispiel gesundheitliche
Einschränkungen können ihren Beruf nicht
mehr ausüben die Statistik zeigt
außerdem dass es vor allem ältere
Menschen und zum Beispiel auch
Alleinerziehende sehr schwer ist wieder
ein Arbeit zu kommen und genau hier geht
es doch darum zu empowern zu
qualifizieren um zu schulen und neue
Rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen damit
Menschen mit gesundheitlichen
Einschränkungen wieder vermittelt werden
können und auch für Alleinerziehende
Kinder eben nicht zur Armutsfalle werden
und genau dafür schaffen wir mit dem
Bürgergeld neue Instrumenten
Möglichkeiten
der Kern der Reform ist dass wir dafür
sorgen wollen dass Menschen in allen
Lebenslagen mit Respekt und auf
Augenhöhe begegnet wird dass sie da
abgeholt werden wo sie stehen das neue
Wege mit den Menschen gemeinsam
erarbeitet werden und nicht gegen sie
dass wir Ihnen grundsätzlich mit
Vertrauen begegnen und nicht immer
überall erstmal Misstrauen sehen das ist
und das ist nicht und das ist nicht nur
was neues werte Kolleginnen und Kollegin
das ist auch was neues für unsere sozial
für Sie werte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sondern auch für unsere
Sozialgesetzgebung und deswegen ist das
Bürgergeld wirklich eine grundlegende
Reform mit der wir was neues anstoßen
und ich freue mich sehr auf das
parlamentarische Verfahren um das
wirklich sehr gute Gesetz noch besser zu
machen vielen Dank
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
DR Markus reiche
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zunächst einmal
Frau Klose ich muss sagen dass sie als
allererste in der Debatte hier das Wort
Faulheit verwendet haben das ist
bestimmt kein Beitrag zum Kulturwandel
den wir hier brauchen
und ich möchte auch sagen
an Herrn Kober sie haben uns ja den
Ratschlag gegeben wir sollen mal die
Gesetzestexte und Begründungen lesen ich
habe das sehr wohl auch schon vorher
gemacht und ich habe dann endlich auch
mal die Antwort darauf gefunden wieso
das Bürgergeld eigentlich Bürgergeld
heißt denn das Bürgergeld heißt
Bürgergeld weil es die Bürger am Ende
eine ganze Menge Geld kosten wird
und
was mir in der Debatte hier wirklich
fehlt ist die Perspektive derer die
dieses Geld über ihre Steuern am Ende
bezahlen werden und für die ist der
Gesetzentwurf so wie er vorliegt eine
Zumutung
ich denke hier mal an die Verkäuferin
zum Beispiel in meiner stammbäckerei in
Dresden die jeden Morgen zuverlässig zur
Arbeit geht und natürlich die erwartet
auch dass eben jemand der vielleicht
gerade nicht arbeiten kann und keine
Arbeit hat dieselbe Bereitschaft und
dieselbe Zuverlässigkeit eben aufbringt
diese diese Verkäuferin hat aber nicht
die Möglichkeit mal sechs Monate zu
sagen zu ihrem Chef ich habe jetzt mal
vertrauenszeit und komme mir mal bitte
nicht mit Erinnerungen an eine Pflichten
Herr Dr Reichel gestatten sie eine
Zwischenfrage oder Bemerkung von Herrn
Kober aus der FDP-Fraktion
Präsidentin sehr geehrter Kollege Dr
Reichel vielen Dank dass Sie die
Zwischenfrage zulassen sie sprechen die
Kosten an die es erfordert von den
Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahlern und
aufzuwenden um die Leistungen des
Sozialgesetzbuches 2 künftig Bürgergeld
zu finanzieren sie haben gesagt sie
haben auch den Gesetzentwurf gelesen ich
empfehle Ihnen zum Beispiel mal die
Lektüre des
bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteils von
2014 wo noch mal eindeutig klargestellt
worden ist dass in unserem Land das
Existenzminimum gewährleistet ist und
gewährleistet bleiben soll und damit
möchte ich Sie fragen wenn sie auf der
einen Seite
aus den Reihen ihrer Fraktion immer
wieder betonen dass der
Inflationsausgleich wichtig ist und
richtig ist gleichzeitig sich auch zum
Grundgesetz und zum
verfassungsgerichtsurteilen bekennen
wollen an welcher Stelle möchten Sie
dann wirklich dieses System dieses
sozialleistungssystems in Frage stellen
ich finde die Diskrepanz die sie hier
aufmachen zwischen sozialen rechten die
sie nicht benennen und auf der anderen
Seite den Kosten für den Steuerzahler
finde ich nicht in Ordnung und ich frage
sie wie sie diesen Widerspruch auflösen
wollen
sehr geehrter Herr Kollege vielen Dank
für Ihre Zwischenfrage und wir müssen
das ja auch miteinander mal
ausdiskutieren es ist natürlich jetzt
nicht hilfreich wenn wir uns
verschiedene Lektüre Vorschläge
wechselseitig geben aber
aber der Punkt worauf wir ja eigentlich
in dieser Debatte hinaus arbeiten ist
die es niemand stellt doch hier also ich
wüsste niemanden der die Erhöhung der
Regelsätze in Frage stellt niemand
ich weiß auch nicht wieso sie da jetzt
so hier ist ins Gelächter ausbrechen es
geht doch um eine Sache mit diesem
Gesetzentwurf werden sie eine ganze
Reihe von Fehlern reizen entweder
einführen oder noch ausbauen die am Ende
dazu führen werden dass die Zahl der
Berechtigten im Ergebnis ausweicht
endlos ausgeweitet werden könnte denken
wir an das Thema mit den überzogenen
vertrauenszeiten denken wir an das Thema
mit den Sanktionen die weit weit unter
dem was auch Sie als der FDP erwartet
haben stehen werden das ist doch eine
Einladung und das ist auch genau das wie
das die Verkäuferin von denen ich gerade
im Ansatz war zu erzählen genau die sagt
wie ist denn das möglich ich muss mir
doch die Frage stellen was vermeiden
von meiner Disziplin und von einer
Zuverlässigkeit mit der ich auf Arbeit
gehe noch übrig bleibt will ich da noch
arbeiten ja oder nein sie stellen das in
frage deswegen sehen wir das wir hier
entsprechende Zugänge ins
grundsicherungssystem haben werden und
das wird die Steuerzahler eine Menge
Geld kosten und da sind wir strikt
dagegen
und ich sage Ihnen auch wir sind doch
hier ich meine wir reden hier jetzt in
diesem wunderschönen Plenum aber ich
meine ich habe zum Beispiel eine gute
bekannt von mir aus meinem Wahlkreis
Anne heißt sie ist über private Probleme
letzten Endes aus dem Arbeitsprozess
rausgefallen sie landete im hartz-system
hat sich dann in die Arbeit
zurückgekämpft und die sagt das doch
auch natürlich will ich arbeiten weil es
mich also weil ich dazu gehören will
weil ich weil ich weil ich teilhaben
will aber Leistung muss ich doch lohnen
sonst fehlt es doch auch mir an
Motivation also das ist das das was die
Menschen am Ende erwarten von dem
grundsicherungssystem und sie wenden
sich davon konsequent jetzt ab
und wir reden doch auch also ich habe es
auf jeden Fall getan intensiv mit den
Mitarbeitern im Jobcenter gesprochen die
Stimmen dem noch zu dass wir hier
falsche Anreize setzen wenn das so
umgesetzt wird das können sie doch nicht
machen auch die Verkäuferin wird am Ende
darauf angewiesen sein dass sie mehr
Netto hat wenn sie arbeitet zuverlässig
zur Arbeit geht als wenn sie das nicht
tut und hier werden wir ansetzen müssen
und nicht nur im Bereich des Bürgergelds
selber sondern auch drumherum wir haben
sie angesprochen energiekostenbremse
wann kommen der denn endlich dazu dass
die Energiekosten tatsächlich entlastet
werden nicht erst im März sondern
frühzeitig denn jeder Euro mehr
Energiekosten bedeutet eben auch wieder
etwas weniger Lohnabstand wieso werden
die Sozialversicherungsbeiträge im
nächsten Jahr in koso-modo beginnen
anzusteigen für alle was dann wiederum
den Lohnabstand versenkt daran können
Sie so können Sie die Politik für die
Sicherung dieses grundsicherungssystems
nicht machen wir stehen für ein
aktivieren Sozialstaat und nicht für
einen alimentierenden sozialstand vielen
Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Markus Reichel aus der Unionsfraktion
nochmal mit dem Tenor der
emissionsrebner insgesamt zum
bürgergeldgesetzentwurf dieses
Bürgergeld zu heißt es mache es den
Beziehern von Grundsicherung alles in
allem zu leicht Wolfgang strengmann Kuhn
war schon fast ampult hat dann was
vergessen hat das jetzt geholt und jetzt
kann er auch anfangen
wenn sie aus dem Buch Vorgehen keine
Sorge frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
es ist wirklich ätzend wie sich die
Argumentationsmuster der beiden Parteien
hier rechts
ähneln und sie sollten mal wirklich
darüber nachdenken von der Union ob das
wirklich Sinn macht und solche
unsachlichen Argumente wie ich heute
gehört habe das ist wirklich ein großes
Problem
eins dieser unsachlichen Argumente ist
dass das Bürger der Vorwurf des
Bürgergeld wäre ein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen
Leute sie machen dabei gleich zwei
Fehler sie machen einen Doppelfehler
erstens ein Grundeinkommen ist eine
Leistung die ohne Bedürftigkeitsprüfung
gezahlt hat das hat uns viele Vorteile
die ich jetzt auf Zeit können gar nicht
eingehen kann und deswegen empfehle ich
insbesondere ihnen von der Union weil
dieses Buch von der
Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung also eine ihnen
da stehende Stiftung wo es um das
grundeinkommensmodell eines ehemaligen
Ministerpräsidenten von ihnen ging lesen
Sie das mal dann wüssten sie wirklich
dann werden die Debatte hier sachlicher
es gibt gute Gründe dafür und deswegen
haben wir Grünen im Grundsatzprogramm
beschlossen dass das eine Leitidee für
uns ist das bedingungslose
Grundeinkommen aber das Bürgergeld ist
eine bedür krankheitsgeprüfte Leistung
und ist gar kein Grundeinkommen fehler
Nummer eins
ein Vorteil des Grundeinkommens
letztendlich bei Fehlernummer 2 ist dass
die Motivation erwerbstätig zu werden
bei einem Grundeinkommen viel höher ist
als in dem jetzigen Hartz IV-System weil
die sogenannte Grenzbelastung viel
geringer ist oder auf übersetzt gesagt
die Leute behalten mehr von ihrem
Erwerbseinkommen bei einem
Grundeinkommen das ist der zweite Fehler
der Vorwurf führt eigentlich völlig ins
Leere und ist falsch
wir haben beim Bürgergeld tatsächlich
auch das Ziel dass mehr vom eigenen
Einkommen überbleibt das ist innerhalb
des grundsicherungssystems nicht so
einfach aber wir bewegen uns auf diesen
Weg und in dem Gesetzentwurf ist ihnen
vielleicht noch nicht aufgefallen haben
wir da auch ein zentralen Punkt nämlich
bei den Menschen die Mehrheit 520 Euro
verdienen die haben nämlich demnächst
bis zu 48 Euro mehr also von wegen
weniger Anreize für Erwerbstätigkeit wir
schaffen mehr Anreize für
Erwerbstätigkeit und wir schaffen auch
mehr Anreize für Weiterbildung durch die
Einführung eines
weiterbildungsgeldes um uns nicht nur im
Bürgergeld sondern auch in der
Arbeitslosenversicherung das dem damit
die Menschen sich Weiterbildung mehr
leisten können wir setzen auf Motivation
sie setzen auf Sanktionen und
Bestrafungen das ist der Unterschied
zwischen der Ampel und ihnen vielen Dank
Wolfgang strengmann Kuhn aus der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen zu Beginn
seiner Rede noch mit einem Buch Tipp zum
Thema bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen
herausgegeben von der Konrad
Adenauer-Stiftung Jana Schimke ist am
pulsiv vorletzte Rednerin in dieser
Debatte und kommt aus der Unionsfraktion
bis zuletzt gehofft dass sie von diesem
Gesetz Abstand nehmen
das sage ich heute ehrlich zu ihnen in
einem Appell an ihre politische Vernunft
wir werden mit diesem Gesetz künftige
finanzielle Mehrbelastungen von 20
Milliarden Euro bis 2026 haben denken
Sie bitte alle daran dass wir jetzt
knapp 100 Milliarden Euro aus dem
Wirtschaft Stabilisierungsfonds ausgeben
zur Bewältigung der Energiekrise 112
Milliarden Euro Bundeszuschuss in die
gesetzliche Rente künftig 2023 hinzu
kommen Einmalzahlungen neue euro-tickets
45 Euro Tickets wohngelterhöhungen und
alles das was die sozialpolitische
Klaviatur in diesem Land sonst zu bieten
hat und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich will mal eins klarstellen wir sind
nicht diejenigen hören Sie doch mal zu
wir sind nicht diejenigen die die
Menschen in diesem Land gegeneinander
ausspielen ihre Politik ihre Politik tut
das aber sehr wohl was glauben Sie denn
warum in den großen Städten dieses
Landes zur Zeit demonstriert wird
das ist genau ihrer Politik geschuldet
und auch das was wir heute hier mit dem
Bürgergeld diskutieren wird da
diskutiert
und meine Damen und Herren alle alle
Wirtschaftsinstitute alle Verbände in
diesem Land warnen vor dem Bürgergeld
und ich sag mal eins ganz deutlich wir
sind nicht dazu da die
trauma-bewältigung der SPD in den Griff
zu kriegen wir sind nicht dazu da die
Luftschlösser der Grünen zu
vervollständigen und wir sind auch nicht
dazu da liebe Kollegen von der FDP das
Bindemittel an ihrem regierungsstuhl zu
sein
meine Damen und Herren der Sozialstaat
wächst als wären wir im Aufschwung dabei
haben wir Inflation wir haben Insolvenz
und die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unseres
Landes geht immer mehr nach unten was
wir jetzt viel mehr bräuchten ist ein
starkes Signal an den Arbeitsmarkt und
keine
Kooperationsvereinbarungen mit
Bedürftigen was wir aber aktuell erleben
ist die maximale Ausweitung staatlicher
Leistungen bei einem massiven Abbau von
Eigenverantwortung sie schaffen das
Solidarprinzip in unserer Gesellschaft
ab auf dass wir so stolz sind weil wir
wissen das Bedürftigkeit in diesem Land
von den Leistungsträgern von den
Menschen die täglich arbeiten auch
getragen werden und die Menschen die
gerade draußen auf die Straße gehen
fühlen sich von ihnen über den Tisch
gezogen weil sie dafür verantwortlich
sind dass Solidarität in diesem Land
künftig zu Einbahnstraße wird und ich
würde mir wünschen dass sei mir als
letzter Satz noch gegönnt dass das
Engagement dass sie in die junge
Generation setzen wenn rund um die
Klimakrise geht dass sie das auch im
Bereich der sozialen Sicherung tun
vielen Dank
Jana Schimke für die Unionsfraktion und
wenn sie sagt alle Institute alle
Verbände warnen vor dem Bürgergeld dann
stimmt das in dieser Ausschließlichkeit
nicht Jens peik ist der letzte Redner in
dieser Debatte und der kommt aus der
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren Abgeordnete wenn man
der letzte Redner ist hat man erst
Privileg die Debatte zusammenfassen zu
können deswegen kann ich jetzt erstmal
feststellen auch nach dem Austausch der
Argumente heute ist ein guter Tag ein
guter Tag für unser Land
ein guter Tag für den Sozialstaaten
sozialen Zusammenhalt unserem Land ein
guter Tag für Menschen Unterstützung
benötigen und auch das ist mir besonders
wichtig ein guter Tag für die
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer in
diesem Land
Herr Stracke von der CDU hat ja zum
Recht darauf hingewiesen dass wir die
Arbeiterparteien in diesem Haus sind und
ich glaube dieser Fokus auch noch mal
bei der gesamten Debatte ganz richtig
denn was tun wir heute wir lösen ein
System ab das unter dem Namen Hartz IV
zu einem Synonym für die Bedrohung von
Menschen wurde für ein System das die
Menschen wahrgenommen haben als eins
dass ihnen nicht half sondern in
gesellschaftlichen Abstieg organisiert
hat ob das richtig ist oder nicht sein
dieser Stelle mal egal Fakt ist diese
Wahrnehmung gab's und sie hat gerade bei
der Arbeit Mittelschicht dazu geführt
dass es Verunsicherung gab
und wer so wie ich
oder die Präsidentin aus dem Ruhrgebiet
kommt der hat Strukturwandel erlebt der
hat erlebt wie Mensch um ihren
Arbeitsplatz bangen mussten und
vollkommen unverschuldet arbeitslos
werden weil höchsten Stahlwerk in
Dortmund geschlossen hat oder Opel sein
Werk im Bochum und das hat immer gleich
tausende oder 10.000 Beschäftigte
gleichzeitig getroffen und deswegen
hatte man keine Chance in dieser Region
wieder ein Arbeitsplatz zu finden und
wenn man dann zum Jobcenter musste dann
hat man sich nicht gedacht oh gott sei
Dank da wird mir geholfen sondern man
hat das als Belastung empfunden
wenn die Menschen aber den Glauben an
die Unterstützung durch die Sozialstaat
verlieren dann haben wir ein Problem
und deswegen werden wir dieses Vertrauen
mit diesem Gesetz jetzt wieder
herstellen wir schaffen ein Kulturwandel
es wird genauso sein ein Kulturwandel
der auch den arbeiten Menschen im Land
sagt wenn ihr unverschuldet arbeitslos
werdet dann bieten wir euch Hilfe es
wird nicht zuerst darum gehen wie groß
eure Wohnung ist ob das Auto was ihr
euch harte arbeitet habt vielleicht zu
teuer ist nein sondern es wird zuerst
darum gehen welche Qualifikationen
bringt ihr mit welche Unterstützung
braucht um schnell wieder ein Arbeit zu
kommen genau dazu dient die Karenzzeit
von zwei Jahren
bei Angemessenheit der wohnungsvermögens
damit Menschen sich nicht zu erst Sorgen
um die Wohnung machen müssen dazu dient
die Abschaffung des vermittlungsvorrangs
weil eine bessere Qualifikation noch
bessere Perspektiven bedeutet
langfristig wieder in Arbeit zu kommen
denn wir wissen noch alle dass wir gut
ausgebildete Fachkräfte brauchen und zu
diesem Kulturwandel gehört auch der
kooperationsplan weil Zusammenarbeit
braucht eben keine Drohung sie braucht
kein Sanktion sondern Zusammenarbeit
braucht halt Augenhöhe sie braucht
Vertrauen das geschaffen wird
und genau deswegen entspricht sie auch
den sozialen Arbeitsmarkt im Paragraphen
16i weil wir niemanden abschreiben wir
schreiben niemanden ab selbst nach
vielen Jahren Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit
werden wir den Menschen wieder eine
Perspektive geben
und genau deswegen
gilt unser Dank auch den Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Jobcenter Herr Witte hat
gerade noch mal gesagt das GB ein
Misstrauen das haben wir an dieser
Stelle schon oft diskutiert nein dieses
Misstrauen gibt es nicht die Kolleginnen
und Kollegen das sage ich weil ich lange
in der Kommunalverwaltung gearbeitet
habe bis zum letzten Jahr die geben
jeden Tag ihr Bestes und das wissen wir
aber nicht die gute Arbeit der
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Jobcenter das
hat das Problem ganz im Gegenteil es ist
doch der gesetzliche Rahmen den wir
geben mit dem die Menschen arbeiten
können und viele Beschäftigte sehen das
doch genauso das sind die Gespräche die
ich mit den Kolleginnen und Kollegen
geführt habe
weil sie wissen dass man mehr tun könnte
und den Menschen zu helfen
und mit der Einführung des Bürgergeldes
dass mir besonders wichtig werden die
Jobcenter zu einem Ort in dem die
Menschen Hilfe erfahren dass auch so
wahrnehmen und damit kommt dieser
kulturband auch bei dem Beschäftigten an
weil die Menschen ihnen anders
gegenübertreten werden und dieses
Vertrauen brauchen wir dringend beim
kommenden Strukturwandel auch bei den
Transformationen und das ist doch der
Unterschied Frau Schimke die Menschen
demonstrieren nicht gegen das Bürgergeld
sie demonstrieren weil sie berechtigte
Sorgen haben und wir schaffen Sicherheit
mit ganz vielen Maßnahmen
entlastungspaketen mit dem Abwehrschirm
und auch mit diesem Gesetz für die
Menschen die um den Arbeitsplatz bangen
müssen wenn die Krise schlimmer wird und
deswegen ist es ein guter Tag weil die
Menschen können wieder Vertrauen in den
Sozialstaat fassen herzlichen Dank
Jens mike war das noch mal für die
SPD-Fraktion in der ersten Beratung
eines
bürgergeldgesetzes dass die
Bundesregierung hier vorgelegt hat eine
teilweise emotional teilweise polemisch
geführte Debatte zum Bürgergeld das
Hartz IV ablösen soll allerlei Fragen
sind nach wie vor offen etwa ob dieser
Kulturwandel den Jens Park eben auch
noch mal angesprochen hat bei der
Arbeitsvermittlung tatsächlich gelingen
kann angesichts des Personals oder der
personalpersonalstärke in beispielsweise
den Jobcentern hier ist aber überwiegend
der Fokus gelegt worden auf die Höhe des
Bürgergeldes und es gibt außerdem
Gesetzentwurf zwei Anträge noch einmal
aus der afd-fraktion und aus der
Linksfraktion alle drei Gesetzentwurf
und Anträge werden im Ausschuss für
Arbeit und Soziales weiter besprochen
werden